Alright, character build, speedrun.
Alright, it looks like me.
I'm getting my hair color.
I'm good to go.
I might need to look a little bit more healthy.
Wait, this game has lore?
I did not know that.
You have 150 hours on this game!
What do you mean?
I don't know, I just thought it was like pew pew pokemon.
Alright, I'm holding F.
Oh my god!
Alright, where's our base?
What are we doing for our base?
Figure it out, motherfucker.
What do you mean?
Where are we building our base?
I'm making a workbench right here.
Basically what we're gonna do is work our way towards where we're gonna set up the base and just catch shit along the way.
If you get lost, just ask the gods where it is.
Alright, no problem.
Let me tab out real quick and ask the gods.
Murder is wrong from our PAL level?
That's a problem.
One of the global events is we have to get 20 humans and put them in the viewing cage.
Oh wow!
That's neat!
I love that!
We had to catch like 5 of them earlier too.
How many people do we already have?
We have 1 people.
Hopefully we're about to have more people.
I will catch people too.
Yeah!
People catching!
This is what we wanted, Nintendo!
This is what we wanted!
I wanna catch Professor Oak.
We got another person.
You got another one?
Anyway, there's a guy down here in the rock.
If anybody has a PAL vault and wanna catch him, he's gonna be here.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Where are you?
You have to hit him in the head because he doesn't have a hitbox.
Yeah, I got him.
No!
I got him out though.
Come on, get over here.
Oh, I got it!
We got it!
Wait!
There's a shiny lamp!
Don't kill it!
We get extra points as well.
I'm beating him up right now.
Oh, I got it!
I got a shiny!
Clip it!
Clip it, chat!
Clip it, bro!
Alright, go kill this sweeper.
Go die, Willow.
I only have a pickaxe, so I'm not helpful.
No, not the babies!
We don't care about the babies!
Oh god, oh god, I might actually die.
Give me that sweeper!
I missed!
Nice!
Clip, clip, I got them!
Another boss down.
Let's go!
We're on our way to get $500.
We're last place right now.
We're already at $500.
Guys, we're sort of 15th place right now.
We're 16 teams, right?
Guys, we're not last!
These things, we can do it so fucking fast.
I'm just saying.
Oh, we just got last place apparently.
Guys, don't worry.
I can speedrun all these bosses and then we're gonna get out of this.
We'll be fine, we'll be fine.
Because all we need is to catch up.
Oh my god, you're level 10!
I didn't even realize.
No, no, I meant like my wolf is level 10.
Yeah, because I forgot I killed the other one accidentally.
You don't lose your pals when you die.
No, but he died because I drowned him accidentally.
I did not!
I had to replace him for a little bit.
Go Fox, go!
I don't have a weapon still because I keep...
Whoa!
He fucking almost one-shot me.
Holy shit.
Do you have a shield?
No, we don't need shields.
Shields are for losers.
I say as I'm about to die.
Can I catch him?
He's definitely dead.
Oh, okay, cool.
More balls, less shields.
That's right.
Please don't get involved.
Come on.
Please, at least give me that!
I got him!
Clip it!
I'm dead though, but I got Grintail.
That's all that matters.
I can't seem to stay alive.
Whoa!
Shiny!
He, like, spawned next to me!
I was like, what am I hearing?
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, I'm going to catch you.
Clip it!
I got him!
That's fine!
I got the fuck.
And I died next to the respawn beacon.
It was worth it.
I'm gonna go capture the quiver right now.
Alright, let's hope I don't die.
Let's go.
Oh shit!
I don't think I'll be fine.
Oh, I don't have arrows.
Why do I keep forgetting to bring arrows?
Trying to catch this man!
Oh no, I'm too strong!
He's dead.
Oh well.
Oh no.
It is what it is.
No!
What is our ranking now?
My chat says that our ranking has not been updated.
Well, to be fair, we haven't really been doing any achievements.
We've just been like progressing.
I got quiver and clip clip clip!
Clip clip clip!
Oh, the cutest fucking pal in the game.
I would die for that thing.
Triph, have you done anything that hasn't been clipped yet?
Uh, I mean I've clipped a bunch of stuff but I haven't submitted anything.
I don't know.
Oh yeah, what have you not submitted?
I just asked them to clip and then I move on.
What is it?
What did you do?
Fuck it, they're in the clips!
I don't know what to tell you man!
What does it mean?
I'm trying to do as much as I can in the small amount of time I have.
What is your mission?
What is your mission right now?
I'm fucking killing the bosses!
What do you think man?
Well, how many bosses have you done?
Fucking like six, seven, I don't know.
Oh, did we even clip seven of Shareforce bosses?
They're in the clips.
We need to make sure we got everything.
Please.
Oh, clip clip clip!
I got the... clip clip clip!
Let's go!
I got the bat!
Okay, I can do one more boss I think.
Okay, I can get the doom mud.
Doom mud, get over here!
The last 10 points right here!
Let's go!
One fucking min-maxing?
Yeah, it was worth a try.
I wanted those tokotokotokos.
But then I had to use like five...
...trazillion balls on one.
Oh, please, please no.
That's a lot of balls.
That is...
Doom mud, I got doom mud clips!
I got doom mud!
Nice!
We got...
MVP!
Okay, how many minutes do I have left?
Oh, one minute.
Okay, that's it.
I got the one we needed.
Alright.
Here we got the one.
And then bot got all of our...
...palace that we captured.
Chill, Sweet, TwoMoss, Doom Mud, Pen King, Azuro, GrinTale, Broncherry.
Right?
We got Broncherry.
Kempaka.
Bushi, Quiverne, Felbat, Natalia, Broncherry Aqua, Warsec, Relaxasaurus.
Is that all of them?
We have everything.
Now we die.
Okay, now we're done.
Yay!
We can start now!
Okay, let's go!
Yay!
Let's go!
I'm ready to clip this when I defeat this tower.
Shoutout to my mods.
Thank you so much for clipping everything yesterday.
You're the realest.
They now have a nickname thanks to Dokie.
They're now called the PP mods.
PP mods?
Which sounds like...
I feel like the bosses just aren't, like, as worth it in this game.
I guess it's like Dark Souls, so it's like...
It's not as rewarding to kill them.
Yeah.
Van Worm, please!
Stop!
Oh my god.
My Van Worm got stuck.
No, why are you hungry?
You're not allowed to starve!
Stop starving!
I didn't tell you!
Stop building!
Get the fucking bug here!
These fucking pals!
The gold-crafted balls!
This is not what I paid you for because you're not getting paid in general.
You're allowed to survive if you make balls.
Yeah.
Earn your food!
Let's go!
Finally!
Assembly line.
Clip this!
Clip, clip, clip, clip!
Boss eliminated!
Clip, clip, clip!
I'm starving.
I'm on HP.
Something's gonna sneeze and I'll die.
Hahaha!
In that moment, we get raided.
Right there.
No help.
Those five berries are for our pals, okay?
They gotta split it between the 14 of them.
Well, now it's too bad.
Now they have zero berries.
Oh ho ho!
Because I'm starving.
Lily's life matters more than the power.
Hahaha!
Exactly!
More easy.
Come on, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Oh shit.
Okay, do my... your turn.
You're level 22.
I think you'll be fine.
Actually, no.
You will not be fine.
Oh shit.
What?
You'll be fine.
Everything will be fine.
Alright, now.
You stay here.
You...
Oh my god.
Why is it 8%?
Alright, clip clip clip.
I got it for a dash.
Clip clip clip.
We got our first medium bosses.
Let's go!
Alright, who's the next boss?
That is a level 38.
I am not high enough level for this.
We don't have a choice.
Trust the process.
Trust the pal.
Trust Lily.
She is a certified pal.
Best pal.
I'm a certified pal.
Look, I'm fighting Lily.
How dare you!
You're fighting Lily?
I'm fighting Lily right now.
We're just friends.
Come on.
No!
Hahaha!
Let's go.
Yeah, I'm gonna beat the fuck out of you.
I'm gonna beat the fuck out of you.
I don't think I can kill the second tower girl.
She's way too strong.
No.
Noob down.
Oh god.
Uhhh... I don't know.
I feel like this is the fastest.
I'm not really...
I knew it was in the fastest.
Clip clip clip!
I finished tower two!
Let's go!
Clip clip clip!
Oh my god.
We did it.
Mine.
Back to work.
Work work.
Enough standing around.
Work work work.
It's time to get back to sleep.
Sweep sweep sweep.
That was fun.
Let's have some more of some time in some time soon.
Okay, you really do sound like the voice from the game though.
You can just tell me that you're the guy from...
You know...
Dude, I would be a sick voice actor.
Get a voice reel right now and apply.
I don't know how that fucking works.
Just have a...
Do I have to join like some voice actors guild or some fucking...
No, I don't think so.
Use your clout.
No, I ain't got clout.
Just be like, I'm a voice actor.
Haha, I'm a voice actor.
Done.
If you never try, you'll never get employed.
I don't want to try.
Why not?
I just want everything to be given to me.
I gotta stop talking like a true content creator.
How to become a voice actor.
Step one.
Declare intent.
It's just that easy.
Amazing.
I can do a... kill the mammarist, right?
Okay, well let's see if I can kill it.
If you need help, good luck.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
If you need help, no one can.
Good luck.
Haha, no one can help you.
But if you need it...
You're on your own.
Oh, this boss is easy.
I'm so fucking tanky now.
Or my pals are tanky.
Go pal, go.
I'm so good at Dark Soulings now.
Leave me alone.
My god, please.
Come on, mammarist.
Alright, let me check for time.
I'm just trying to catch my mammarist.
Why is it 5%?
This mammarist is taking fucking forever.
Oh my god, I think I definitely need a hyperspear or some shit.
What are the mats for hyperspear?
I have... we have all the mats.
I just can't kill them.
We need circuit boards.
I need to build this.
Oh, so mammarist is caught.
Clip, clip, clip.
I got it.
Are you guys all ready for dungeon?
Yes.
Alright, alright.
Let's go find the...
Oh, yeah.
Make sure you don't get hit.
Just keep running.
Wait, did you get a wolf finally?
Pee pee.
I forgot to fucking bring it though.
I might die actually.
Pee pee, no.
I am consenting to witnessing a murder.
I am consenting to witnessing a murder right now.
911, please.
There's a murder happening right now.
Go, Panky.
Go, Vam.
Go, little guy.
You got this.
Well, I am just going to watch.
I don't have any fucking weapons anymore.
Yay, murder.
Yay.
Are you going to catch him?
No.
Clip, clip, clip.
Pee pee, Vam.
Alright.
Nice.
Watch.
Alright.
Clip, clip, clip.
We are here!
We have life sanctuary 2.
Alright, I am leaving.
Goodbye.
Alright, clip, clip, clip.
Alright.
Clip, clip, clip.
Bye.
You guys wanna do the petting now?
Yeah.
Let's do water first.
Let's just go in order.
Alright, 3, 2, 1, go.
There you go.
Clip, clip, clip!
Alright, water's done.
Okay, well we have like 30 minutes, so you guys like...
Let's try to speedrun this.
Surefour and I can finish the rest of the bosses.
I'll try to build the...
We need to be at level 20 as well to make the zoo with 20 people in it.
Yeah, alright.
Surefour, do you wanna do the black marketeers right now with me?
I found the black marketeer, level 40.
Fuck him up.
Let's go.
We gotta capture him.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's...
Yeah, he's getting fucked up.
I'm a little over -encumbered.
Nice.
12 percenter.
Let's go.
We got one of the black marketeers.
We just need one more.
Clip that!
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip us catching that one, then get it later.
My game's done.
I'm base level 20!
Clip, clip, clip!
Base level 20.
Alright, viewing cage.
But we also need you to put in the humans.
I'm putting in humans.
How do I put the humans in?
You walk up to it and hit X.
Okay.
Um...
I died.
How many do they need?
Okay, I'm putting more than three.
They're all gonna be in there.
Alright!
Clip, clip, clip!
Viewing cage!
We need like two more!
Alright!
Surefour, you need to be back by three minutes if you can, so we can do the chickpea.
I'm getting the butcher knives.
Do we have to do it all at the same time?
I think so.
We should all get together, then.
We need to do this fast, because I need to go get my shit.
Let me know when you guys are ready.
How do I cleave them?
Uh, put it in your inventory.
Put it in your inventory.
Wait, I have it in my inventory, but I don't have a butcher option.
You have to be holding it.
Yeah, hold it.
Hold it.
Wait, hold it?
I can't hold it.
You, you...
Weapon slot!
Quick!
Time is of essence!
I need to get level 50!
Put it in the weapon slot!
What do you mean?
You just dragged it there!
Take away one of your items!
Alright, you guys are bugged.
You guys might have to re-log.
You have to re-log.
There's no other way to explain it other than just put it in your weapon slot.
That's the only way we can win.
That's literally all you do.
What do you mean?
You're picked at!
You're literally bugged.
You have to re-log.
I just re-logged.
And now I can't put it in my weapon slot.
Yeah, just re-log.
I still haven't re-logged!
What do you mean?
Put it in your weapon slot!
Re-log!
No shot!
Okay, wait, I've got it.
It's there.
It's not working anymore.
I got it.
I'm gonna put it in my weapon slot.
No way you're thinking that, Brenn!
What?
I go downstairs and butcher this chicken.
Finally.
All right, I'm downstairs.
Let's go.
All right, press.
Remember to press four.
One.
Go!
Butcher!
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip, clip!
Got it.
We got it.
It's right there.
You have one minute to get to level 50.
I'm gonna get to level 50.
What can you do in one minute or 30 seconds?
36 seconds.
I can't.
I can't kill a boss.
Okay, I don't think we can get that in 30 seconds.
Your statue.
You know what, though?
We did really good.
Oh, we did pretty well.
We did pretty good.
If only I got 50, man.
If only I got 150, man.
We almost got 120, man.
That was the most stressful last five minutes.
Holy .
Top 3 guys!
I can't believe it everyone!
Top fucking 3!
Plus 1!
Holy shit that was so fun!
When we started I still can't believe it.
The last 3 minutes we were just screaming at each other.
We were just like, guys!
I hope you guys had a great time with us today.
I'm really happy with my team, with PeePee, Chatlily and Surefour.
It was a great team.
So thank you everybody!
I'm gonna call it here.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!